we've been talking about this for a long  time fire risk on the rise all across  the west along with extreme  drought and the threat to farming and  wildlife the great salt lake is expected  to reach its lowest point in modern  history  this year the entire state actually of  utah is experiencing drought  more than 90 percent is considered  extreme  utah is the second driest state in the  country but is some of the highest  public water consumption per capita  utah governor spencer cox has now  declared a state of emergency  and called on the people of utah to  reduce their water use and  pray for rain the question is are state  leaders willing to accept  that this is not a short-term drought  but that this is  long-term climate change utah feeds the  colorado river and less water in the  state  means trouble downstream and that  impacts 40 million people  in seven states